ce qui pour moi est merveilleux, qui est le Son Jarocho,
ils ont fini de jouer et ils étaient...
Je vais à leur rencontre, très emu,
pour leur remercier pour ce cadeau
et un jeune garçon me dit :
« C'est que... »
et il le dit avec la meilleur des intentions, il dit :
« C'est que nous sommes très fiers, monsieur,
de garder nos racines, les plus pures,
de notre identité mexicaine. »
Et, moi, franchement, je n'ai pas su trop quoi dire.
(Rires)
Je suis resté immobile, je l'ai embrassé et je suis parti, mais...
Car il avait raison aussi, n'est-ce pas ?
En effet, la decima fait partie de ses origines,
mais aussi, tout comme dans la milonga et dans la decima,
il y a des origines de beaucoup plus de peuples d'ailleurs, comme il a dit.
Ensuite, à l'hôtel, j'ai réfléchi à cela pendant un moment.
Et j'ai dit :
Les choses ne sont pures que
si on les regarde de loin.
C'est très important de connaître nos origines,
de savoir d'où on vient, de comprendre notre histoire.
Mais également, comme il est important de connaître ses origines,
il est important de comprendre que nous tous, au fond,
nous ne sommes de nulle part totalement,
et de partout un peu.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Voici « la milonga du maure juif ».
(Musique)
Pour chaque mur, un gémissement à Jérusalem, la ville dorée
et un millier de vies gâchées, pour chaque commandement.
Je suis poussière dans ton vent et même si je saigne de ta blessure,
et chaque rocher aimé garde mon amour, le plus profond,
Il n'y a pas de pierre au monde qui vaille autant qu'une vie.
Je suis un maure juif, qui vit avec des chrétiens,
Je ne sais pas quel dieu est le mien, ni quels sont mes frères.
Il n'y a pas de mort qui ne me fasse pas mal,
il n'y a pas de côté des vainqueurs,
il n'y a rien d'autre que de la douleur, et un autre vie qui s'envole.
La guerre est une très mauvaise école, peu importe en quoi elle se déguise,
désolé si je ne m'enrôle pas sous aucun drapeau,
Il vaut mieux n'importe quelle chimère, qu'un bout de tissu triste.
Je suis un maure juif, qui vit avec des chrétiens,
Je ne sais pas quel dieu est le mien, ni quels sont mes frères.
Et je n'ai autorisé personne pour tuer en mon nom,
un homme n'est pas plus qu'un homme et s'il y a un Dieu, ainsi il l'a voulu.
Le sol que je foule continuera d'exister quand je serai parti
aussi vers l'oubli, comme toutes les doctrines le feront,
Et il n'y a pas de peuple qui ne se soit pas cru
être le peuple élu.
Je suis un maure juif, qui vit avec des chrétiens,
Je ne sais pas quel dieu est le mien, ni quels sont mes frères.
Je suis un maure juif, qui vit avec des chrétiens.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.